over 19. the origin is the top story but
the
but the focus of this administration on
vaccination
is uh mind boggling listen in many cases
they've done a very good job getting the
word out
and getting the vaccine out from johnson
johnson to pfizer to moderna
they're available if you want them but
that's not enough now you need to be
berated by none other than dr
fauci because you're playing politics
that's the reason
you may have not gotten it listen
this is not complicated we're not asking
anybody to make any political statement
one way or another
we're saying try and save your life and
that of your family
and that of the community here we have a
vaccine
that's highly highly effective it's easy
to get
it's free and it's readily available so
you know you've got to ask what is the
problem
get over it get over this political
statement just get over it
and try and save the lives of yourself
and your family
assumption is to think that you're not
getting the vaccine if it is indeed the
case
uh because of politics maybe you had
the you had the virus already maybe you
know you have the antibodies
uh maybe the fact that it's emergency
use doesn't make you feel comfortable
why not give people credit rather than
try to berate them into doing something
and claiming it's playing politics well
and does your doctor talk to you that
way he's clearly get over it get over it
you have to
take this shot no you talk to your
doctor about your choices
and you as an individual as an adult get
to make those decisions
what if you have a 15 year old and you
watch fox and friends when brian
interviewed the dad whose son
it hurts every time his heart beats he
tells his dad
after he got the shot he can't play
soccer anymore
and no telling how long he'll deal with
these you know with these issues
i'm not saying don't get your kids
vaccinated that's your choice as a
parent
but you have to outweigh you have to
know all the facts and when fauci says
get over it
what do you say to that dad dr fauci do
you tell him to get over it his son
can't play soccer anymore and he's a
really good athlete get over it we're
saving your life
doctors give you recommendations and
information if
i go in and i'm morbidly obese and he
says stop eating so much steak pete
i get to go home and choose whether or
not what my next meal looks like
same thing here we have a lot of
information you know what your health
background is
age you're responsible for your kids to
shame people to get a vaccine
is not effective and it worries people
that that will turn eventually into a
mandate when this is no longer emergency
use
when schools are reopening that's when i
think we'll have a real crosstalk
because we don't know are they going to
mandate schools
have to get this shot and how are they
going to prove that you got the shot
so and if you don't get the shot you're
going to be told to get off campus
and then we'll have to see how that goes
but
dr jeannette neshwat joined us earlier
and talked about some of the patients
she has seen and the reasons they don't
get the vaccine
when i ask my patients kindly and
respectfully why they're not vaccinated
the small percentage that are not they
never tell me well i don't know where to
go
what i hear from my patients is they
just haven't had a chance due to work
schedule or family schedule also some of
them still have a lot of unanswered
questions that need to be addressed
i take that opportunity to answer and
address those questions and a very small
percentage
are just not ready and don't want the
vaccine so again it's important to
provide that information
provide that education and let them make
that decision that's best for them
personal choice i believe you know yeah
i'm fine with leaders saying
please please please that's fine i'll
i'll make the choice then as a result
you've given me the information
and that's what she's reinforcing they
know where to get the vaccine it's like
every drug store or grocery store across
the country
yeah there's no doubt about it more we
have city we have all these
pop-up you know um doctors these small
little
on every corner i mean you know where to
get a vaccine if you don't you can
easily ask your friend who got a vaccine
where do i go
a plus they're going to be knocking on
your door soon so go home check your
ring doorbell
anthony thought you might be there in a
smock it'll be fantastic and a cotton
ball
uh we'll see how that goes please uh
show your just have your deltoid ready
to go
uh with your black please do like would
you like pete oh you have his tank tops
when you're not on the show
no sleeves most of the time at home i am
wearing a tank you're willing to take a
shot at it ready to go
you're a tank top kind of guy are you i
don't want to take that characterization
right
you could pull it off julian and i had
this conversation one time
we're not we're not into the tank tops
on guys but if you
have them it's okay what if it's a
basketball jersey i have a chris
john starks those are good okay right
very similar players